et nous sommes avec olivier antoine
directeur doha géopolitique un cabinet
de conseil en prospectus géopolitique
spécialisé sur l'amérique du sud bonjour
à vous merci d'être en direct avec nous
à la dette de l'argentine représentent
environ 90 % de son pib le pays est en
défaut de paiement
l'inflation semble incontrôlable est ce
qu'on va vers un effondrement total du
pays un scénario similaire à celui de
non je ne crois pas parce que le défaut
de paiement en fait est un défaut
virtuel a il faut avoir à l'esprit que
depuis un an l'argentine est
virtuellement défaut de paiement ça fait
un an qu'elle ne peut plus honorer ses
dettes et que différents alors une
élection présidentielle est passée par
là donc le nouveau gouvernement essaye
de rattraper un petit peu les erreurs du
gouvernement précédent malheureusement
locaux vides est venue est venu mettre
vraiment une pression maximale sur des
négociations de renégociation des dettes
aujourd'hui les 50% de l'inflation alors
il faut les prendre sur une durée de 12
mois et elle était en train de baisser
et le co vide là aussi est venu mettre
un coup d'arrêt à certains efforts
portés par le gouvernement évidemment le
panorama est absolument noir les
difficile de dire que l'argentine va
pouvoir se redresser de la foi de son
endettement
duco vide aujourd'hui beaucoup
commencent à s'impatienter
malheureusement il faut avoir à l'esprit
que l'argentine entre en période
hivernale
donc même si on ne sait pas bien si le
virus est saisonnier il apparaît évident
que c'est la période à laquelle les
contagions sont les plus fortes
notamment pour la grippe
donc on a du mal à imaginer que
l'économie puisse redémarrer aussi
simplement alors qu' il serait de bon
ton pour toute la population de rester
confinés le pays est en train de rôle de
négocier la restructuration de sa dette
et le président alberto fernandez il dit
vouloir rester intraitable alors nous
allons payer autant possible pas un
millimètre de plus c'est ce qu'il dit
quelle est la main
de manoeuvre pour ce pays face à ses
créanciers allez allez allez un film
c'est très paradoxal
elle est infime et l énorme master que
aujourd'hui le la première question
qu'on pourrait se poser c'est comment le
pays a pu encore arriver à un tel niveau
de d'endettement pourquoi le l'année il
ya deux ans le fmi a fait intel en prêt
à l'argentine sachant que l'argentine
était vraiment dans de très mauvaises
conditions financières économiques à ce
moment-là et l'histoire plaide en faveur
de défaut de paiement donc c'était assez
assez curieux que le fmi soit aussi
laxiste aussi facile dans ces conditions
auprès de l'argentine aujourd'hui
paradoxalement le meilleur allié de
l'argentine c'est le fmi dire que le fmi
elle ne peut pas participer des
restructurations dette avec les fonds
privés mais essaye tente de la de
persuader les fonds privés de trouver
des accords qui soit juste pour que
l'argentine puisse honorer une partie de
ses dettes et puisse se reconstruire
pourquoi simplement parce que le fmi
comme les fonds privés
ils se hissent ont entre les mains un
petit peu entre eux en compétition ils
cherchent tous les deux à pouvoir
obtenir quelque chose de l'argentine
donc oui c'est un film parce que
évidemment le pays est acculé par ces
bêtes
le pays aujourd'hui avec la crise de
kovy de voir son horizon vraiment
s'obscurcir mais en même temps il ya des
il ya une réelle possibilité que
l'argentine puisse avancer parce que il
reste encore quelques marges de
manoeuvre parce que le fmi ce n'est pas
non plus n'importe quels alliés à
l'heure des négociations alors le le
fonds blackrock c'est l'un des
principaux détenteurs de la dette
argentine
il est considéré comme l'un des plus
intransigeants 6 quelle est votre
analyse sur ses rapports avec buenos
aires et bien l'analyse est simple
c'est un ennemi de longue date de
l'argentine
le gouvernement précédent le boudin en
maille de marussia macri avait accepté
de paille et de payer une dette qu'elle
devait aux fonds blackrock d'être qui
avait été levée le fruit d'une longue
bataille judiciaire dans les tribunaux
de new york entre le gouvernement de
crédit cristina fernandez de kirchner
d'un côté et ce fonds blackrock pour
pour situer le fonds blackrock
aujourd'hui c'est une gestion de plus de
6000 milliards de dollars d'actifs
certains pour avoir une idée une idée de
comparaison ces trois fois le pib de la
france
un petit peu moins de trois fois le pib
de la france donc c'est énorme
l'argentine évidemment de ne peut pas
vraiment rivaliser face à un tel fonds
mais l'argentine fait valoir fait valoir
ses droits
le problème c'est que ce les différents
emprunts qui ont été faits sur les
marchés internationaux auprès de fonds
comme blackrock ont des clauses ou qui
permettent à ces fonds de porter devant
des tribunaux internationaux et donc les
tribunaux des pays d'origine de ces
fonds dans ce cas là les états unis leur
requête des ça c'est peut-être le plus
difficile pour l'argentine c'est que ce
ne sont pas des tribunaux ne ce ne sont
pas des tribunaux internationaux
d'organismes multilatéraux sont des
tribunaux de la justice étasunienne
donc pour l'instant l'histoire nous dit
qu'à chaque fois l'argentine a perdu
elle risque de perdre à nouveau face à
aux fonds blackrock si le fonds
blackrock reste aussi intransigeant ce
qui a l'air d'être le cas
crise économique crise sanitaire est ce
qu'il faut craindre également à votre
avait une crise humanitaire en argentine
oui complètement
aujourd'hui l'argentine
quand le nouveau gouvernement a pris les
rênes du pays l'argentine était vraiment
faisait face à une situation absolument
catastrophique plus de 30% de pauvreté
depuis le début de la crise de comme il
faut
imaginez que les écoles ont fermé dans
énormément de quartiers populaires les
écoles ça signifiait le seul le moment
de la journée où les enfants pour avoir
une ration alimentaire équilibré
complète donc ils n'ont plus accès à ces
rations là il y à quelques scandales qui
est qui explose ci et là à buenos aires
ou de rations qui ne sont plus
distribués ou quand elles sont
distribuées elles sont de vraiment de
piètre qualité
donc on est face à une explosion de la
pauvreté qu'il était déjà relativement
importante
une difficulté un paradoxe quand à la
possibilité d'obtenir danser dans les
quartiers précarisés de la nourriture
alors que le pays est l'un des plus
grands exportateurs mondiaux de matières
premières agricoles du soja du maïs de
la viande mais aujourd'hui il est
difficile pour les quartiers pour les
personnes et quartiers les plus pauvres
de pouvoir obtenir d'une alimentation de
base donc le gouvernement agit tant bien
que mal sur les prix il essaye de
contrôler l'inflation mais comme vous le
savez bien
l'inflation continue à grimper même si
elle a ralenti dernièrement grâce au
contrôle du gouvernement mais elle est
toujours aussi forte
donc c'est les gens n'ayant plus de
moyens non plus de sortir de chez eux
souvent dans ces quartiers bas le fait
de pouvoir sortir c'était le fait de
pouvoir exercer un travail à l'extérieur
souvent du travail informel qui soit
légale illégale mais merci beaucoup
on doit rendra donc c'est pour ça que je
me permets de vous interrompre en tout
cas je rappelle que diriger le cabinet
aura géopolitique un cabinet en conseils
de conseil en prospectus géopolitique
spécialisé sur l'amérique du sud merci à
vous